cela fait des années que le sahel est en
proie à un conflit armé particulièrement
éprouvant pour les populations locales
des groupes djihadistes opère notamment
dans ces cinq pays désormais regroupées
sous l'appellation g5 celle une
structure appuyée par la présence des
forces militaires françaises à travers
l'opération barkan parmi les missions de
ce g5 sel se trouve la coordination des
forces militaires locales pour faire
face aux groupes armés
c'est l'un des aspects les plus délicats
de cette opération la formation et la
montée en compétence des armées locales
et ce ne sont pas les révélations
d'amnesty international qui vont
contribuer à l'amélioration du climat
sur place selon un rapport de l'ol j'ai
entre février et avril de cette année
les forces de défense et de sécurité au
mali au burkina faso et au niger se
serait rendu coupable d'un certain
nombre d'exactions 199 incidents sont
répertoriés dans le document 57 cas
d'exécutions extrajudiciaires ou
d'homicides illégaux ont été relevés et
142 cas de disparitions forcées ont été
constatés amnesty international publie
ainsi des témoignages d'habitants qui
ont subi ces exactions
parmi les nombreux récits que l'on peut
lire il y a notamment celui qui revient
sur la journée du 7 février dernier où
une patrouille des forces de sécurité
maliennes se rend dans le village de
massat bogou selon le rapport 22
personnes auraient été arrêtées et huit
autres auraient été exécutés par les
soldats voici ce que raconte un témoin
ils les membres des forces de sécurité
et de défense sont arrivés dans le
village vers 17h tirs en l'air et
arrêtant des villageois
de nombreuses personnes ont fui ou sans
rester dans leurs maisons après
l'arrivée des soldats ils ont passé les
maison au peigne fin exécuté de manière
extrajudiciaire huit villageois et
emmener les autres le document expose de
nombreux récits similaires au niger et
au burkina faso
une situation qui pourrait être
sous-estimée et qui a un impact
considérable sur la situation des
populations locales déjà menacée par la
présence de groupes armés de gea liste
l'insécurité règne au sahel où la
population est piégé entre les attaques
des groupes armés les opérations
militaires en cours
on sait que l'armée procède à chaque
fois des dizaines d'arrestations
arbitraires et que certaines des
personnes arrêtées ne réapparaisse
jamais mais on ignore l'ampleur réelle
des violations commises par les forces
de sécurité amnesty international se dit
très préoccupé par ces violations des
droits humains
les ong demandent l'ouverture d'
enquêtes et le cas échéant la suspension
des personnes concernées mais elle
demande aussi aux partenaires des pays
en question d'appeler les autorités
locales à faire respecter le droit
international humanitaire
pour certains ces agissements découle de
manière plus ou moins directe du sommet
du g5 celle qui s'est tenue en janvier
dernier à pau c'est ce qui explique
ousmane diallo chercheur à amnesty
international
il y as certainement une pression
politique auprès des armées du mali du
niger et du burkina et cela se traduit
naturellement par un relâchement de
leurs méthodes opératoires notamment ce
qui concerne le respect du droit humain
et le droit international humanitaire
à en croire les différentes enquêtes
menées ces derniers mois ces agissements
fautifs serait en hausse une situation
particulièrement alarmante car elle est
susceptible de renforcer l'instabilité
dans la région déjà rongé par la menace
djihadiste jusqu'à présent l'opinion
publique se montrait particulièrement
véhémente contre les forces militaires
étrangères notamment l'armée française
avec la révélation de ces exactions
cette défiance pourrait se diriger aussi
vers les forces armées locales et
compliquer encore davantage une
opération déjà très délicate